good job wet so why did you think you're
really cool I mean this is funny to me
that this is what you define as being a
really cool person tell me tell us yeah
all the listeners
those are old-school airplane headphones
yeah before people this is when people
had Walkmans I'm like in elementary
school yeah and I think I took a trip to
Florida on spring break because everyone
in Connecticut goes to Florida same as
Michigan except we one go to Florida we
go to Michiganders would go to like
white more white-trash Florida you guys
a podcast coast yeah we go Daytona would
you guys go east go no I I've been to
Daytona
that's why so trashy and I kept the
headphones you're supposed to give him
back whoa five dollars
Wow there are five dollars in that you
have to return them and then I would
keep them you're crazy and I thought I
was so cool and I brought him to school
the next day oh yeah and I came back
with a tan yeah and the American
Airlines yeah yeah well that was a big
thing is Florida Spring Break still a
big thing or that we've gotten older and
move past it yeah I I think Tulum is a
big thing everyone going to Tulum what's
to lose Tulum Mexico okay if you google
image Tulum is the photos are insane
really it's like it looks like a
Caribbean I feel like it puts the shame
I feel like if I if I ran a warm city
that was the mayor I would just make
sure my google image game was strong
yeah because I I decide to go places
paid above Google in ass and I never go
to page two let's see the real Tulum
also like make sure your Instagram tags
are like on poles they better be on
point because that's how people are
making decisions to travel now you're
into the gram tag
I think Instagram well you do you do
like hash tag Ibiza and then you see
like we're like okay I've done hash tag
Tulum have you and like stalks people in
Tulum do you ever do hashtag and then
misspelled a common one like I did
hashtag on Spotify I did hashtag
mmm not M&M and it like I flipped them
yeah that playlist has like 40,000
followers felt like so many people
misspelled and follow if you do hashtag
and you spell LeBron James like Leblon
blames it's thousands of tweets that's
how stupid we oh my god yeah so funny
yeah like day I bet you hashtag Dan moon
people are probably trying to T tweet
and he trying to tweet to Dana moon
that's my alter ego Dan moon yeah I was
supposed to be a boy and the doctors
told my mom they're having a boy they
said that and her whole pregnancy and I
was gonna be Warren Moon Warren Moon why
would they do that to you
Warren one Harold man Perelman and you
but the thing is you do still have a
penis correct yeah so they're okay
why did they think you were kind of a
you must have had some male genitalia no
it was back in like the late 80s when
doctors took the ultrasound and they
confused umbilical cords with dick oh
yeah they took like a can you say Jax on
your show and say whatever you would
like you also don't have to look in the
camera but you can hi camera hi usually
nur you can say Weiner that was also
back then when they would shoot like
high radiation x-ray into the woman's
stomach to like determine how are we not
all dead right now we should be dead
okay this this thing up to our face okay
I think about that alone this is a
terrible thing I got rid of my microwave
good yeah and I thought I'm like helping
and then I realized also it's like I'm
on my phone so model terrible I'm on
social and I'm true I'm actively like
telling my brain to not do it yeah cuz I
know how terrible it is and then I keep
doing it even more so this is what I've
been doing and I'm this is a
recommendation to you and into you
whenever I grab my phone because
normally when I scroll through Instagram
or Twitter normally I end up angry
somehow like easy life question whose or
some comic I hate is more successful
than me or whatever the [ __ ] case
maybe some girl that I didn't think was
attractive and and wanted to date me
years ago now looks [ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
probably because she has 900 filters on
it so now what I've been doing Dan
is I grab my phone and I start to hit
the Instagram and I go a little bit
lower and I go to PBS or NPR news and I
try to read something that that would
help my brain I like that that works one
out of four times I actually execute it
but it makes me feel better like oh I
just learned that Libya is a not a state
in the United States because I press
that button speaking of social media I
don't I don't need you to respond to
what I just said because you look like I
do have I have two responses and I
didn't know which one to do okay that's
what my brain was doing either way which
way can you pick one and do it I go to
this is what happens when I get
overwhelmed the social media Oh God
I don't know spiritual no I want to hear
this out this stuff is funny but it's
actually helpful oh my god I go to these
accounts and I read about like recension
updates ascension of and like how we're
evolving an energy update oh no oh god
did you get aware I know I know I'm not
like say Kelly though there's like that
fake spirituality that everyone's doing
because it's like trendy throws and it's
all like I'm better than you because I'm
spiritual and I was like that's ego and
that's hashtag hating anything about
true spirituality nope anyways so I'll
go to the new earth this is the new
earth what is I got a we'll look it up
and there's one that's called sink but
it's there there's no K there's a C and
the bio is there is no ceiling guys here
I know it's a Twitter Instagram for
Instagram
awaken conscious collective unconscious
okay not alert yeah I know I wish you
would have picked the other reaction yet
to be no next joke it's a joke but I
hate to do now I'm regretting I'm
regretting everything I've said so far
don't you know how people always post
boxing videos of them like training
boxing the only way that okay so that
makes me laugh because like we get it
you're like coordinated and athletic and
everything that I could can't be it not
even though they're not they're not even
like good at boxing but I always laughed
like hoop why is nobody posting the
meditation video because it's like
that's not what it's about it's about
just being spiritual inside of yourself
do people post meditation videos no no
how many funny though let me look
through it just feels like social media
right now I'm so sick of it like
everyone is just like look what I'm
doing I'm with this person I'm here and
it's like I look up but it's like and I
feel like people are now doing fun
things yeah just so they can post a
phone you're sure is that a fair this
weekend or look I'll keep my kid is for
sure
people think like I don't want to go to
the but I want to show people wanna show
pigs have a cool life but that's why I
like your social media because you're
you're a comedian and you are just using
it to do weird characters and fun thinks
it's not like look at Dana gay on comedy
it's comedy now let me read you the last
well I sent you a direct message after
we work together somewhere where was the
show maybe it may be the basement show
basement shall I always see it the
basement child's a fun show are you a
pastor I'm gonna be past there yeah this
is that the what's the hotel Victoria so
hotel such a cool room I said the
Victorian Santa Monica I think yeah this
is this was my message to you how do you
like my [ __ ] versus how do you like my
dick was making me laugh today great
joke now that's a joke Dana does I don't
just send messages to say how do you
like my [ __ ] i tick I look at what I
never I said ever I said that when you
said that to me I was like oh here we go
Michael coming in hot what I just like
to start with a how do you like my [ __ ]
I mean it was explaining to our
listeners what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about I had an encounter I was hooking
up with a guy an encounter actually I
kept poking up with him and he was so
dumb yeah and the joke is that he's so
dumb that even his dirty talk in bed was
stupid
yeah right and the whole tight like he's
still doing the joke I'm still doing the
joke and I added a little DJ bit on the
end of it because you know I do because
I do my impersonation of him saying uh
do you like my dick do you like my dick
do you like my dick yeah and I might
elope almost and I'm like can you switch
it up like this is
this is too much but he's like do you
like my gosh
do you like my cadres yeah so dumb like
that they literally and that's a hundred
percent true and so now I'm like what do
you would like you sound like a the
world's shittiest DJ at a club just like
like my dick like my dick dude
yeah yeah and I kind of keep going off
it and then I don't know [ __ ] this
guy I did unfortunately goes to show
fellas like you can be dumb and they'll
still and they can make fun of you
onstage in front of others and they will
still have sex with you
is he hot body or what hot body it looks
like Rob he looks like Rob Lowe Wow is
it's not Rob Lowe it's not Rob Lowe but
like he looks like John Stamos and Rob
Lowe Wow like so hot and that's and I'm
so vain I didn't realize how vain I was
your until I kept sleeping with him
because of how Hollywood but yeah that's
that's that's not necessarily vain on
you it's nice when a perfectly sculpted
body is just crushing your guts you know
man
yeah but you know what took away from it
what it the dirty talk really took later
than that bad at it he was that bad and
he wouldn't stop and then he literally
came o to me talking about his dick that
was when I had to stop because that's
too that's too much so you go that's
just ego so we we is this too graphic
because I'm I'm good and I love it you
love if you wanna I talk I had no filter
bring it on and I have no dad I talk
about everything I have no boundaries
bring it on this is this is an all
things comedy yeah Illinois goes the
first time we had sex two times in one
night and the first time he could not
orgasm Wow
and I did and I was like it was kind of
a weird thing that happens after where
you're like one one person doesn't it
it's always a little weird there's like
kind of like tension in the room and so
I was like I was ready to just be like
okay thanks for coming over bye
but then he did the whole thing where
I'm like sometimes I need to lay down
wow so tightly so then he's like
pretending to nap and then he's like
trying to like hook up again and then
the second time we have sex
he's like some psycho same same night
music tell me like my dick tell me like
and I'm like god
and I'm like I'm like yeah yeah that's
our dick and he's like what else I'm
like it's good and so he's like really
getting turned on right is by me singing
I love your deck I loaded this so I just
kept doing it yeah and the more I did it
the more he was like his everything
changed
Wow and he came instantly and then I was
like don't came to me talking about your
deck yeah like I don't even need to be
here yeah you could just you could just
be ordered your voice and he could just
come jerking off yeah
isn't that like that is to me that is
such a turn-off where I'm like how much
are you obsessed with yourself that yeah
or maybe he's just super insecure and he
needs that validation to orgasm
either way it's sad I don't know
anything about sex therapy but it
fascinates me because some some people
would know the answer to that question
in fact you can email me Michael at
Michael Kosta comp if you know the
answer to that question but I don't know
some people enjoy
yeah like positive maybe he has a maybe
he's uncomfortable with his dick you
have a good dick he's great it's so
great it's a great day it's brilliant oh
he has a great dick and he wants to be
told that he has a great day all right
so proud for me it's just falling in it
here you did it is a little insecure but
sex is sex is wherever your whole psyche
is like if you're the super confident
good-looking guy in bed lots of times
you're like the [ __ ] meat guy or like
the the strong CEO woman wants to be
like [ __ ] punch in the face like dirt
Roy and I mean it is like it's it's such
a different personality isn't it yeah
I'm so fascinated I'm so fascinated with
sex and how other people do it and even
last night I was like right on with my
friend and we were like we just stopped
because we thought we heard my neighbors
having sex yeah and I literally put my
head on the ground I'm like I need to
hear what's going on down there and
she's like what are you doing and I'm
like I don't know this is really weird
you want to hear I was at a hotel once
and people were next we're having sex
and she kept saying tell me you love me
oh and he kept saying I feel like a man
so yeah I know so it was tell me you
love me I feel like a man tell me you
love me which is so funny because it
sums up to me it's
the male/female perfectly both people
aren't getting what they want like she
wants them to just go look I love you
this is beautiful and yes like I just
want to [ __ ] feel like a man's
perfect it has like at every male/female
relationship yeah it's like it's um I
believe we call that a microcosm um it's
fascinating and there's got to be some
good sex podcasts out there to get more
information I don't know any but there
must be right sex people sex podcast
there was a girl named psalm Isidora
that knew a lot about sex and i met we
met her on Playboy channel and I also
saw her at the pool at a hotel and she
was taking tons and tons of selfies and
she had these big fake tits and she's on
my Instagram she recently committed
suicide what so sorry Psalm yeah she did
she was a sex therapist and you know
what she put out this total positive
vibe all the time and then you just read
that she ended her life which is really
sad I know hey speaking of now to talk
about worse birthdays move in moving on
very quickly when is your birthday
daenam November 13th I I was born on
Friday the 13th
oh right out of the gate yeah I love
that idea [ __ ] right away so here's what
we're going to do Dana we're going to
read a listeners worst birthday and I
want your feedback on this birthday okay
I'm going to read it to you this comes
from Adam :
he's I think he's in Colorado but and
then we'll get into yours is that cool
perfect okay ladies and gentlemen if you
would like to share your worst birthday
on this podcast you can either email me
michael michael kozakov also email me
and let Dana know about that whole
telling this guy that he had a nice dick
thing I would love more information yeah
like that what sex what does that mean
that he gets off to Dana saying you have
a nice dick now what if you said like
you have great ABS would that get him
off
why's that like that's funny was this a
dick thing yeah your [ __ ] pot or your
body hot would that get him or was it
just his dick I think it was just a dick
yeah yeah and he was in a was he in a
physical position of power at that point
was he on top yeah so maybe it says he
wants to [ __ ] him like be told he's the
king
I think so yeah okay or ladies and
gentlemen you can call and leave put a
funny segue or you can call and leave
your worst birthday as a voicemail under
three minutes please call 909 five to
worst nine oh nine five two worst so
this is Adam that your personal found
with my personal stuff
no it's a Google Voice but there's
instructions on how to leave a voicemail
I would love some voicemails because
it's fun to play know how people don't
do that anymore those Millennials are
like what are you talking about The
Voice now or you can email me this comes
from Adam Cohen
I'm gonna I'm gonna give you the
highlights and then I want to hear what
you think about this okay
hey Michael cos this is the best podcast
in the whole world did he write that he
didn't holy [ __ ] this isn't I couldn't
think of a worse birthday here it is but
then I thought it was 18th birthday
first question yes big deal right is it
big deal 18 what do you think yeah you
can go to strip club strip club you can
buy cigarettes you can buy cigarettes
pretty cool FF&E that sums up Dana Moon
right there you can go to the strip club
and buy six yeah you can also you can
also fight in the war can you buy a gun
can you go out with buy a gun you can
always take on you know in this country
you can always like my birthday was
overshadow due to the fact that I
graduated high school that day at Red
Rocks Amphitheatre in Colorado
shout out nice there we go Red Rocks he
got off to a pretty [ __ ] start my
parents at the time were in the middle
of their divorce so things weren't the
best but both my mom and dad's family
flew in from Chicago and Phoenix to be
at my graduation and obviously it was
[ __ ] awkward time because they were
forced to see each other and our too
childish to put things aside for one day
okay
yet what this is not your parents what's
what's your parent parental deal
divorced divorced dad dad dad dad
divorced family when did the divorce
happen in your life at what age oh dear
ten ten and when nine or ten when did
your father pass fourteen fourteen
terrible time you have no choice but to
be a stand-up guy I heard and I'm the
third born Wow and I was the one that
was like they were over it by the time I
came in the family
do you know Rene Gautier do you guys do
a podcast you know do you know Renee
Renee does a podcast called the dead
dad's Club and it's all comics that have
lost their fathers it's offense it's
it's a it's a podcast about that's humor
and grief how I love that yeah I'll put
you guys in touch she's lost she's been
on the worst birthday pocket graduation
happened and it was the worst taking
pictures with everyone looking like a
family even though we weren't that's
kind of sad then some genius thought it
would be a fantastic idea if we all got
dinner together we were at this Chinese
food place there was a huge long table
the first five minutes were alright both
families asking about my future going to
college all that [ __ ] and then there was
about 20 words spoken it was very
awkward dinner he sums up his night by
saying it was fun because we got to go
watch the Stanley Cup Finals okay
awkward dinners you've had awkward
family day yes okay probably not with
your dad though because he died he's not
here yeah yeah sorry so this is the
actual worst birthday right here so the
next day the day after my actual
birthday my high school hockey team had
our end-of-the-year party both sides of
the family ended up coming to that since
we were all in town I was super [ __ ]
pumped for this this is what always
starts a good bad birthday expectation
excitement I yeah and my family I was
super [ __ ] pumped for this because I
was the only four-year varsity player on
the team and this was my goddamn moment
and time okay Adam but things got dicey
real quick my dad and his family were at
table to my left my tables in the middle
and my mom and his family her family's
tables to the right all of a sudden
there was arguing I wasn't sure about it
and I didn't get involved and then my
aunt screams across the restaurant
you're a pathetic excuse of a man
robbing your ex-wife in this divorce
then my dad screams back oh you're such
a [ __ ] you don't know anything there
were plenty more things said I put my
hand I put my head in my hands like what
the [ __ ] is going on other parents had
to break up this fight which is funny at
a hockey banquet and I finally received
my four-year letter looking back it's
actually kind of funny because all the
adults were acting like children it was
an interesting and stressful weekend
what do you think about that day what
does this say about me that I think all
about Tulare yesterday you're laughing
at
well he you know he this is Adam : Thank
You Adam for cinnamon and he says I hope
you laughed at my pain and I and we did
we did well here's the thing don't like
everyone has a dysfunctional family yeah
and you know you're 18 it was the day
after your birthday Adam yes
so what grown up yeah you know I think
it's funny that they probably held it
together on the actual birthday and then
the next day they were like it's not at
a birthday anymore and they just lost
their [ __ ] yeah do you remember your the
divorce when you were 10 oh it was
terrible was oh my god so what can you
deny parents were anything you want to
know my parents were separated and they
were trying to get sides like like my
mom and dad wanted you know wanted us to
be my mom wanted her to be on our side
and my dad want to be and there's three
dudes and there's three kids too and my
so my dad moved out and I mean I wasn't
surprised when when I knew about all of
us but my dad moved out into a motel 6
whoa and then he started drinking real
heavily he did and I remember the scene
from the movie
goddammit the Chevy Chase Christmas
vacation was Asia where the opening
scene the opening scene where the car
goes under the tractor-trailer truck yes
yeah that was my dad ah I mean that was
your dad that was just he got it he was
driving drunk and made a right turn
right under a tractor-trailer try and
went under the truck yeah and literally
so like broke his hip yeah it doesn't
just drive all perfect like it's like a
movement you actually just have audited
his car was crushed oh yeah and the
doctors were like we don't know how he
survived and he was drinking in response
to life being at the shitty time yeah
dang at a motel 6
stana mojo 6 so then so on top of that
so then my mom doesn't even let him back
in the house yeah he still had a goddamn
motel 6 all [ __ ] up in her on crutches
yeah
my mom wouldn't drop us off to go see
him so you know he would he had to wait
to get better to come pick us up oh it's
terrible and and he came to pick us up
and he's like hobble and I'm like you
live in a moat motel 6 but to me like
now I just I think motel 6 I think it's
hilarious yeah but I think I are a dark
sense of humor yeah you will duh
if you think that that's hilarious I
picture your dad like in a [ __ ] neck
brace at a motel 6 and you're laughing
your ass off about it why is the guy
always have to go to the [ __ ] hotel no I
mean I'm not saying like maybe he [ __ ]
up or whatever but it know he's knocked
out of course he [ __ ] up but it is a
two-way street
my mom is yeah my mom's out of her mind
insane and just provoked him yeah and
then he's in the motel 6 can't see his
kids I'm not defending your father I'm
yeah anyways what what would you you
know what what would you tell Adam Adam
seems like a grown man now he seems like
he's laughing at it but any you know
you've got Adam yeah it's awkward when
both of your parents are together and
they're in the same room and they're
getting divorced and they're not
together but like at least one of them
still alive you know what I mean I need
to pull that hard I'm pulling that card
right now but I remember during the
divorce all the family events were
awkward and like I you know my brother
graduating from high school and my mom
and dad being in a photo together it was
so weird
but now you know it's like I graduate
college and it's like he's not even
there yeah so take the awkwardness yeah
I think that's good you know what I mean
like it's a little weird but like are
you gonna do that's life dude
everyone everyone goes through that I
think that's I think that's really good
I think it helped me to learn that every
family is screwed up it's almost like
when you like like my sister has been
sober 12 13 years I don't know I love
you TTS doing kicking ass and I remember
like at first we were all afraid to like
say it out loud to people like
Christie's you know had drinking too
much and now she's sober as soon as you
just go like oh she's she's sober
everyone's like oh yeah my uncles or my
brother my son my yeah like it's like
everyone's got this [ __ ] we should be
able to talk more openly but I say
exactly it's very weird that that people
want to put on this like front but
they're all like perfect being
because we're not we're all flawed and
also I think the families who who act
like they are so perfect are you crazy
oh [ __ ] you're the craziest it's like
the grass now cloud the people that I'm
the people that hate gays are you hey
yeah everybody knows you're gay i right
my brother is very straight easy you're
wondering but he comes to LA and he just
wants to go to book let's go to Boys
Town for real which it wasn't hilarious
trip on boys tent like he called West
Hollywood Boys Town yeah it is [ __ ]
boys because we're good at rage no but
he just like he thinks it's hilarious
that there's like rainbow crosswalks and
flags and gay dudes everywhere and you
like glucose goes a little baguette so
everything's over there like jerking off
yeah I'm like I think you can't I think
you're straight but I also think you you
kind of like have that I had this art
item and I had this conversation with
Sabrina Jalees who was married to a
woman she's a female I love all these
shoutouts and well I'd like to include
include the the peeps you'll be shot out
you know in the future but she was
saying like Michael if a guy was sucking
your dick it would feel good right and I
was like yeah and I was like that does
that does I literally said I think that
disgusts me
and she said the fact that you're
reacting so negative shows that you are
a little bit gay and I was like okay
like I'm down to be open-minded and go
with this but I don't think it does but
then she's like if you just close your
eyes you didn't know who it was would it
feel good the answer is yes yeah what if
he had a wig on never would a
clean-shaven oh my god
yeah and you wouldn't know was really
good-looking but that doesn't mean by
the way this was her point of fact that
you're reacting like this shows that you
you probably are gay well okay I had a
lot of feelings about this filming and I
think that also okay also I think a guy
sucking a guy's dick would be way better
than a girl sucking guys oh god knows
what are you doing yeah I feel like any
gay dude can like run laps around
a second-deck way better than me I agree
with you but isn't the site for a woman
eating another woman out oh you don't
know you finish your sentence I'm sorry
no no no that's fine I think that um I
think there's a spectrum good right and
so like in the middle is you know
bisexual right in each end gay straight
and I think that all human beings are
kind of on no one's completely gay no
one's completely sure I think we're kind
of on some spectrum and the people who
aren't comfortable with it like I think
my brother's a little bit on a spectrum
the people who aren't comfortable with
it and don't understand when these like
normal feelings and like desires pop up
they judge it and they shame themselves
and they go to all these like different
I guess crazy justifications you don't
have those reactions and I think it's
normal
where's your brother live Connecticut is
he religious no yeah I mean he's kind of
like the thug it's kind of Suggs kind of
like gangster it's always not Nathan
I mean I'm exaggerating it yeah it's
also sometimes like you know when I grew
up I grew up in Ann Arbor Michigan which
was which was pretty progressive and but
it was still at a time when there's a
cool place it's a very cool place but it
was a time when it wasn't like so openly
gay I remember like when you'd see guys
holding hands you would kind of because
it was so different you'd be like kind
of looking at I'm different and stuff
but maybe I just because you're not
weren't exposed to it maybe your bro
just wants to go down [ __ ] Santa
Monica Boulevard me me I mean it feels
like he can't for the other man yeah
interesting Dana
November 13th yeah smile for the camera
this is Brennan little comic oh I'm
Brandon um I know we know I know you do
everybody knows Brendan who doesn't know
Brendan
that's so obvious I literally just
stopped in with took a fixative thing
tell me about born Friday to Friday the
13th tell me about your worst birthday
or you say maybe of a couple of them I
have a couple of them do you Tommy um my
12th birthday Wow my long memories of it
huh very strong memory I I hide it at my
dad's house and so he led two towns over
so he's out of the motel six now he's at
the motel 6
he's a homeowner no I lived was my age
he lives with my brother and my sister
and I go there on weekends and so I
wanted to have the custody was brother
with dad you girls with mom he would
kind of swap or whatever and my brother
never went the weekends with my mom
really it was just I just saw him every
other weekend when I went to my dad
which now looking back is that still a
custody thing because that's that's very
sad
are people only getting to see their
kids every other weekend I don't know
the answer to that because that's not a
lot of time to see your kids I feel like
it is that now I feel like someone that
always wins custody that would devastate
me
I know and then is my guess I can only
see my kids every other weekend I don't
understand and maybe this is just my
naivete I don't know why a divorced
couple can't just like be somewhat
rational with the kids because someone's
hurt because somebody's hurt both
parties are hurt yeah and everybody gets
hurt [ __ ] someone gets [ __ ]
financially yeah yeah the person was
[ __ ] emotionally and replied for and
so it just it's just good it's it's
adults that are hurt it's yeah it's so
unfortunate yeah I think that there's
some mature divorced couples who kind of
split it 50/50 because that is so unfair
especially if both parents are capable
and loving yeah to get two days with
your kids 42 weekend out of a 2-week
that sucks that's that that's four days
out of a month
yeah and that's eight days out of two
months yeah you know and that in it but
I can't go I can't go more than that
sixteen days I don't know know what a
you're 12 birthday so I had it on my
dad's house so my dad kind of my mom was
more like the the strict parental like
there's a lot of rules and my dad you
know half the time he was he was pretty
lit and so he kind of let us do we would
go there we would get r-rated movies he
loved me where we wanted whatever
friends wanted to come over like it was
so I was excited this is my first
birthday party at dad's house and I knew
I could do whatever the [ __ ] I want to
do so I invite I think there's like six
or seven girls and we're doing a
sleepover nice
and I have my friend Danielle who lived
down the street from me and I was up
doing what I Danielle cabal's it blowed
up closer so she uh her and I were real
tight and we were always getting into
trouble doing dumb [ __ ] you know and I
had a plan right okay so I was obsessed
with the movie scream I know you did
last summer do all those horror flicks
right I Freddy vs. Jason how any movie
where someone's being stabbed to death I
was like other into it I'm like you've
always had a dark sense of humor
obviously that kind of shows that so I
didn't know so I'm turning 12 and all
the girls are like 10 11 12 I had no
idea that these type of movies affect
young girl sure and I guess it's a
normal way they get scared and they cry
and they whatever whatever yes
so I so we have all these movies that
we're going to watch okay good and then
I have a plan with Danielle would mom
have let you watch this movie no no no
no I have a plan I have a plan with
Danielle we are going to after the scary
movies we're going to go take a walk and
we're going to see something that
happened next door so a plan was that we
see a murder
oh that's I just I was all my idea we
happen to see a man stabbing a woman to
death which by the way has never
happened in the state of Connecticut no
brother never happened in Cheshire
Connecticut yeah somebody fell once on a
squash court and injured themselves okay
so this is a good plan okay so in my
mind I'm going to trick I'm going to get
all these girls good this is a fun prank
so my dad this is so this is the night
where we start watching the movies and
like halfway through there are some
girls that are like they they can't take
the movie it's too real yeah and they
were like even the room and like one was
like getting all upset and I was like
this is the perfect time Danielle let's
go for our walk
actually I want to take a walk so then
we for some reason we're all in the
basement my dad had a finished basement
which I thought was so cool finished
base I wanted to finish it I will at all
I wish we would this podcast could be
sponsored by the
with a finished basement so dope so I
climbed through the window nice ah
totally unnecessary Ming and crying
continues me and we're like oh my god we
just saw the neighbors getting murdered
he stabbed her what do we do and and
then all of the girls who were like
losing their [ __ ] over watching like
scream just start hysterically crying
one is like calling her mom the other
ones like can you go wake up your dad
and I mean you did pretend to see a
murder that's like a serious crime it's
I like we saw em is like one of them
called their mom to come pick them up
she could not stay and I remember
everyone was so upset with me yeah and
in my mind is your dad my dad was big
sleeping quick passed out so you see the
scary movie and then you're kind of like
did you actually go on the walk or do we
went on the walk and then that you could
really ran in screaming ran back
screaming we just saw murder and that
was the point that I'm like I'm gonna
prank them all yeah and I yeah I don't
think I thought it through no I think
that's correct everybody was very mad at
me yeah half of the people call their
parents sleep and their parents were mad
yeah cuz it was like midnight
yeah and they had to come pick them up
and no one really did you eventually say
like this is a joke
nobody and then they had yeah they had
to explain like she said she saw murder
and I'm like you know I just thought it
was all good good fun yeah I thought it
was good clean fun well you know we
learn how to be funny because that is a
funny idea but now you would probably go
let's not do murder
let's save your scene let's say we've
seen a couple ghosts or something
they're like is it you know what's crazy
is that was too much I'm 12
yeah you know what I mean is dark yes
like that's very young to be like let's
trick all your girlfriend's and to a man
to sing a murder and a man kill the wife
to I bet you that was after - dad
stabbed I bet you that was a little bit
of a divorce maybe kid brain out
dad stabs mom every and I mean every
time I would like play house yeah with
my flipper with my friends
there would always be like there'd be
like one uncle that's still there that's
still living there yeah and then there
would be a third always be like ice it
would be like you know step mom and dad
and the dad was abusive
oops really Oh what was your dad abusive
to your mom not physically yeah but
definitely like I definitely like
mentally there's all different types of
abuse but Lakers yeah every time like
even when I would play house it would be
this one there's be dysfunctional well
but I'm not a psychologist but that that
makes sense yeah Anna maybe it was a
good outlet for you I think I think that
that's how I survived because I was just
always in my imagination I was always
playing and I go making things up yeah
do you still love scary movies you do
yeah
so that could just be an innate thing
you just like murder and death like
what's one of your favorite I mean it
does make like we snuck out of the house
a couple times and we always said like
we saw something weird or that the
homeless guy we saw him walking around
but you saw a man stabbing a woman that
is like a full-on criminal offense like
like you would be subpoenaed and
testified in court if that actually
happened yeah and there's no call the
police I was like you can just because
you guys got I was trying to get them to
go over there it was like very weird
that's funny though but I ruined my
sister's birthday
so is this this is another oh that's
right you said okay
yeah your sisters older than you she's
two years older and this must have been
like her eighth or ninth birthday oh man
nice what happy 10th she's always had
more friends than me what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I know and she's always had
friends um like since like they were
like kindergarten
okay what's her name hi pup Marissa I'm
Marissa hey Morris so she's had friends
from like they've known each other since
they were like almost babies and they've
still been close friends so I was always
envious of her and yeah so she had a lot
of friends over and she was getting ah
so I was already pissed yeah because she
just a lot of friends she's more popular
than you and I you know I was there and
I and no one really no one really paid
attention yeah and oh I know this yeah
his brother that happen all the time it
sucks yeah yeah so I saw out the gate
I'm pet she's I need attention we needed
to attend especially comedians and I you
know I was kind of quiet and I was kind
of sulking foremost party and then it
got to present time whose house is this
one I have from the families together
the families together go yeah I think
honestly I think I was like six or seven
I was so young but I remember this
specifically also my sister brings it up
all the time though estate that's good
and so she was getting every egg you
know her friends were giving her nice
thoughtful gift yeah and you know she
was just like getting so excited opening
them up and I'm directly across we're at
the dining room table she's at one end
I'm at the other end like eyes lowered
glaring glaring all her friends are
surrounding her my mom's taking photos
you know my dad's there he sober it's
great and he comes to the last gift and
I it was Montel Williams Wow this is how
we do it you notice that tape because
Montell Jordan Williams you may he may
do it Muslims was the TV guy right on is
it Montell Jordan Montell Jordan is this
married oh yeah we do it's Friday night
how good was out wrong exact that and he
just goes into rap I still like that oh
my god oh my so this is this is a final
gift tape it's a cassette tape suite and
my sisters freaking out your favorite
song yeah all her friends are freaking
out had to buy the album then just buy
the song my song a very horrible
cassette tape so then it could go to the
Millennials but I mean you know you'd
s'more or less I think I was like 7
bucks the oven was like nine come on
just buy the whole thing
despite all [ __ ] thing and be
disappointed we have to explain what
cassette tapes are Millennials and
gentlemen here's no I think they have
known that yeah so I lost it I start
hysterically crying jealous I was like
this isn't fair because after every gift
that she opened up I would make a
comment because I wanted it right and I
would go I didn't I didn't get that
right at my party
and she's like when's her birthday in
June because one sec much different
timeframe yes so I you know I set it up
oh I grab the tape I start crying oh my
gosh and I just started I was like
sitting I just kept screaming this isn't
fair
right and my mom was like honey to leave
early so my mom told me to go to my room
and I wouldn't go to my room so I just
sat in the hallway crying and this is
Justin I ruined her I ruined her
birthday and all of her friends came out
and sat next to me they felt bad that I
was crying oh and my sister lost her
friends to this day because of crazy
sister Dan Dana and then uh I mean
that's pretty it's pretty it's childish
but it is kind of a natural reaction a
little bit right you wanted you wanted
the affection and attention and I didn't
get it you didn't get it and she you
know she always got it yeah why why does
she always get cuz she was just older
not popular she was always more popular
yeah so you would say brother my sister
were always like the cool kids they
wouldn't make jokes about like the hey
we just saw the neighbors starving life
to death apparently my fam my family I
think was always a little terrified of
me I could see that like I was just very
weird like there were bushes next to our
house yeah that you can go inside they
were like very large it was like a tree
bush and I spent a lot of my time in
there isn't that interesting and they
would they would be playing sports with
their friends yeah well I was in the
bushes talking to people that weren't
but you're a likable pretty woman why
was why were you the weird girl in the
bush I do you know what I didn't want to
do what they want to it wasn't fun for
me yeah playing like sports in I wanted
to just kind of like live in my own
reality I don't know I guess do are you
did as high school went on did you
develop a group of friends do you still
have a group of friends are you just a
little bit of an isolated out like I
know I a lot of drama gripes outliers I
think I had friends yeah but I wasn't I
never really connected with my
highschool friends yeah I had a lot of
high school friends and I'd you know I
feel like I was I was cool in high
school because of my sister my brother
really yeah I think I was like oh she's
a moon like the moons are cool I the
moons are cool and it was it was because
my brother my sister was super like
athletic and like likable and like what
did you do in high school I went to
whydid track and field's guys yeah yeah
but but I'm not coordinated so I can
only do track and field
okay that's still pretty cool though and
but then I did I went to to so into a
theater school go so I went to two
schools and literally there was like a
short bus that would come no jokes
yeah the tiny boss will come and pick me
up and take me to the Hartford called
Hartford performing arts school in the
city and I would just take classes there
till like 4:00 did anybody make you feel
inferior other than yourself
no it was always yeah it was you I think
as my guess is and I'm sorry to cut you
off but I guess is you were as cool and
as friendly and as popular as your
brother and sister but I didn't feel
that way you didn't feel that way yeah
that's probably accurate yeah just
because of my interactions with you and
obviously I've made you much later in
your life than this but as a young girl
until 19 you're still not sure Dana
moon is 19 according to IMDB page just
being updated right now
I had really awesome older still do have
awesome older siblings and they're just
the coolest in your brain oh my god when
you're in middle school and high school
and yeah the girls they hang out with
were so pretty and they had boobs like
the guys they hung and my sister hang
out the guys and they were always cool
and they could like drive I mean you're
just no one you can't live up to your
older sibling it's impossible
yeah and I thought my brother was so
cool because he was like having sex yeah
he was and I was like he's probably fine
he's probably thinking about it dude
when he was doing right what's your
brother's name
Wayne what's that way when I way that
way birthdays that's why birthdays yeah
so amazing as a kid you were so you
couldn't wait to turn 13 yeah couldn't
wait to 1415 yeah oh my god I'm 16 I can
go get my learner's permit it was
amazing and now I'm like
oh [ __ ] my friend has had his birthday
this Saturday and I said would you guys
do for this birthday and he literally
just said you know this wasn't a year
that I wanted to like celebrate and I
was like had such an adult thing to say
and I don't like that he said that
because that's like come on bro it's
always had it is that fun but it's like
you don't have that when you're 12
you know what mom and dad I'd like to
skip this birthday I just wasn't a good
year for me no it's your [ __ ]
birthday I can get some Attell Williams
might know Williams you know what I mean
God Montel Williams is really benefiting
from having the same name as not the way
of goddess girls Montessori
there's a lot of great stuff in your
history and if I was it'd be fun to have
a psychologist analyze how this divorce
may have affected you and is your like
kind way of saying I need to go to a
psychologist oh that's not I do I
definitely do have you been it affects
the way I date for sure oh yeah I mean
it affects like your relationship with
anyone's with one's relationship with
parents affects who you end up with in
life period
yeah but I think every youngest kid
needs attention my whole reason I do
stand-up is because I'm literally
picture myself sitting at the dinner
table being like can somebody [ __ ]
talk to me
everyone's talking to John about school
and Christy and I'm like I'm here here I
think you're not black yeah in most
comics our youngest yeah I had to that's
why as an adult I am ridiculous and I
act I feel like people are like you're
like I'm an idiot I'm doing anything for
a laugh sure because that was the only
way I could get attention is right
saying the most real thing doing the
most ridiculous thing and just like yeah
committing to it and like half the time
it would work half the time I would get
laugh and then I would get attention and
then from there on out I was like oh
this is what I have to do yeah
to get attention I need laughs and now
what's cool about your job is you found
an outlet for it that isn't a
psychopathic one it's a little
psychopathic it is a little sensible
you're right but you're not like
tricking people into there was murder as
I care you don't work at some
corporation as like an accountant and
you do this weird [ __ ] on this you know
like this is your you know you're
getting rewarded in your profession for
doing this which by the way people
should watch your videos and you're on
Instagram Instagram is what she does all
these funny weird characters and they're
just so silly and stupid and funny thank
you
what's what's your Instagram at Dana
moon me OK at Dana moon me and then
what's the video can you describe for
our listeners because I haven't seen in
a while but it's you is it you and Josh
Nasar and there's like the llama in the
background oh did you watch all TED talk
video I haven't watched that I did I
haven't seen everything you've done but
the one that I've watched everything
right I watched I haven't so now that's
wrote what's the one where you at the
end there's like a live animal in your
apartment yes well that's not my
favorite video that's such a funny video
I'm on YouTube just what what's our
YouTube L datum just datum own YouTube
channel on YouTube and datum on OK and
it will come up I show my name um Tina
moon me okay so uh Josh this is what I
live with him Josh does like he'll do
like TED talk inspirational speeches
host stuff whatever and he's giving a
very like motivational speech to camera
that's right and I'm in the back trying
to get attention and doing really
ridiculous physical just kind of what
we're talking about right now yeah
someone else is getting attention and
but he's the funny part is he's not even
acknowledging it and the best part is
that some people who watch it are like I
really liked your message because it was
a very awesome fear when he was saying
that very sincere I was like you know
inspirational words and they're like you
know but it was a little distracting
that there were someone in the
background trying to get attendance like
there was a couple people that didn't
and that to me that's that's very funny
I feel like nailed it
that's like exactly what you wanted some
people that don't get it no it kind of
makes me happier than people who are
like lol yeah buddy funny joke we get it
you know that's funny what Danny was
doing like they don't realize that the
whole bit was you in the background they
actually thought it was like great
message Josh how funny to me that's a
really funny video and make sure you
hold on and there's a lot there's a lot
of funny videos but might went well one
of my favorite things we did a show
called the comments section where all we
did was cover stories that happened in
that week but
only the comments section so not the
actual story and the headline that we
covered one time was man drowns in Demi
Moore's pool okay
Demi Moore was in England this man
drowned in her pool here in LA okay
all of the comments were we lost a great
actress today r.i.p Demi Moore everybody
thought she was dead no one read the
[ __ ] article it was like people just
skim it so I can tie your video there
like list trying to listen to Josh's
message meanwhile you're in the back
[ __ ] around it's like that's the
[ __ ] joke idiots yeah and I'm also
like removing my clothes yes yes and I
ran I ran out in a trash bag which I'm
sorry it's very funny wearing nothing
but trash bag very funny
what's a what we will finish with this
what is a your favorite birthday you've
had I put you on the spot is a great day
anything that comes to mind
Oh 21 I know that's basic but uh 21 I
was new to I just transferred to USC
when I was 20 so when I turned 21 and
really have any friends yeah and I was
trying to get back home to do the whole
21 celebration yeah and it's just that I
was in the middle of a semester and I
couldn't and I was I was really bummed
because I didn't have friends out here
yet I didn't know anybody Yeah right and
my one roommate just joined a sorority
and she got a group of like 20 girls
together well we go out and celebrate we
went to saddle ranch which one Universal
Studio studio is my first time at saddle
ranch that is my first time at Universal
Studios I thought I was the [ __ ] yeah
I'm like Universal Studios it is called
amazing yeah yeah saddle ranch oh my god
you can ride a [ __ ] mechanical bull
and if I have boobs they do like the
boob they hit the button that like makes
the boobs just Larian toasters yeah and
they hooked up they they gave us so many
like free shots and like call us fly you
know when I was 21 I had I literally
thought I was going to be alone on my
21st birthday yeah and then end up being
stranded by like an awesome group of
girls that's awesome getting super drunk
at saddle ranch in Nice of your roommate
right that's a really nice roommate
thing I would recommend to everybody
listening or watching or whatever if
there's someone's birthday coming up
that's new to an area or you don't
really know if
they have friends or you why don't you
just money to be with them and why don't
you organize some even if it's small I
would go a long way yeah it really does
that something I like I still think
about randomly when I'm I don't ever
really think about birthdays but like if
that does pop up I'm like that was a
good birthday like that was unexpectedly
fun and that's also because low
expectations yeah a long way they do so
now I don't have any expectations last
question on your 12th when you pretended
to see a murder
did anybody sing a happy birthday yes
they did the girls did because probably
prior to that prior to them crying and
then Eve oliver's and calling their
parents
uh Dana moon thank you for sharing your
your worst birthday and the fact that
you ruined your sister's worst birth
ruin the sister's birthday
Dana Moon is your Twitter handle dinner
moon me Dana moon me in tribute
everything your YouTube is Dana moon
yeah damage is good just Google venema
anything else that you would like to
share with our listeners to find you
yeah just uh you know hit me up on insta
do that [ __ ] girl me up on Twitter baby
I mean me think I have it anymore
sharing your your stories we appreciate
hope they weren't too dark they're great
perfect
too dark would have been I murdered this
woman I'm now coming although the last
what brand toe boy he tried to kill his
dad on his [ __ ] birthday wait what
yeah I think tops that that's all he
actually tried to poison him with
penicillin he was allergic to it that's
out that should be out this already
gonna be out by the time it's supposed
to thank you Dana moon bye thank you bye
that's great thank you very much